in compact Matt our car chest arena's
Petry says howdy is used to pepping up
it's a three compact there now
presenting the third-generation s3 which
was first introduced back in nineteen
ninety nine inna says Audi's made some
adjustments to make it even more dynamic
like the wait for instance
aluminum components make the car 17
kilos lighter in front than its
predecessor overall the new s3 weigh 60
kilos less than the old model yet puts
out 26 kilowatts or 35 horsepower more
power we're testing the version with a
six-speed S tronic transmission the
driver can also shift gears using the
rocker switches on the steering wheel
greater power and less weight make for
more dynamic handling so does the sports
car chassis set two and a half
centimeters lower than the regular one
putting the driver closer to the road at
the back for oval chrome-plated exhaust
pipes are integrated into the diffuser
at high speeds the rear roof spoiler
steps up contact pressure on the rear
axle
the s3 is powered by a newly developed
turbocharged two-liter T SFI engine
featuring direct injection technology
compared with its predecessor the motor
is smaller and five kilos lighter
gazonga hi howdys Jurgen corn poop says
the special thing about it is that the
exhaust turbocharger was integrated into
the exhaust manifold he explains that
the boost pressure is 1.2 bar which
helped lower fuel consumption the 6.9
liters per 100 kilometers according to
the EU norm cycle that's 1.5 liters less
than on the previous model for all
Kingdom [ __ ] out my school completa
para tinkin the engine puts out 221
kilowatts of power and develops a
maximum of 380 newton meters of torque
the s tronic dual-clutch transmission
rockets the s3 from 0 to 100 kilometers
an hour in just 4.8 seconds modern
thermal management ensures that fuel is
burned in a way that's more efficient
and environmentally friendly and the
sound of the s3's engine is truly
seductive
technical commences eNOS knows that you
could select different driving programs
at the push of a button she says for
drivers the dynamic mode is probably the
most interesting one it makes for quick
acceleration but a rather hard ride so
if you've got passengers on board she
recommends using comfort mode then they
won't get quite so shaken up by the
uncompromising ly sporty ride
the sports steering wheel is flattened
at the bottom making it easy to hold
and the aluminum trim gear shifter is a
work of art the navigation system is
integrated into the dashboard and
vanishes when it's not needed
the s3 also impresses with its sense of
spaciousness for a two-door model it
offers rear seat passengers a surprising
amount of leg and Headroom
you
but the nicest place to be in an s3 is
in the driver's seat and here Audi
offers another innovation progressive
steering
by the progressive Lincoln within your
good corn post explains how progressive
steering varies the steering ratio Becca
wasn't lengthening so if the steering
angle is large the steering
automatically becomes more direct a
snake if I broke relative Enoch Lincoln
schlock woman because it's a common in
comparison to other vehicles this means
when driving around curves he only needs
to perform tiny steer emotions and that
makes a real difference when it comes to
the s3 sporty and lively handling a
sensor also monitors drivers steering
behavior and recommends taking a break
if they're not paying enough attention
to the road so what's ennis is ver
[ __ ] she says the s3 combines
practicality with driving pleasure with
its technical finesse and ninety one
more kilowatts of power and more than
outruns the most powerful a3 and audi
stable vanina's looks forward to audi's
four-door s3 sportback which should
prove even more practical Mia I talked
all disguise
while showing off its facelifted
Panamera at the shanghai motor show
porsche unveiled its new engine range
the 4.8 liter 8 cylinder naturally
aspirated engines of the Panamera S and
4s have been replaced by a smaller 3
liter twin-turbo v6 engine that enables
the sport sedan to use twenty percent
less fuel but gives it 15 kilowatts more
power and absence torque by 20 Newton
metres mercedes-benz trucks presents the
new erics the heavy-duty truck often
used on construction sites is available
in a range of different axle and drive
configurations from a dual axle model
with rear-wheel drive to a for axial
eight wheeler with all-wheel drive the
aurochs shares its engine with the new
actros the street model for
mercedes-benz trunks all the trucks
conform to the Euro 6 emission standard
that goes into effect in 2014
East assorted indycar Chester Sasha can
op we'll be test driving what he calls
the legitimate successor to the
legendary 205 GTI the pujo 208 GTI he
says the GTI delighted drivers 20 years
ago now he'll see what the new one can
do with the new 208 GTI Cujo is hoping
to build on its well-founded success the
basic model is the regular 208 a fun
little car that's been on the market now
for over a year the changes start with a
chassis the 208 GTI is front axle make
for more accurate steering especially at
high speeds
in logic nap is familiar with the GTI's
engine from the [ __ ] ors easy which was
a product of a cooperation with BMW soon
saw bas Mitzvah in Vega vism the 208 GTI
differs from the regular 208 in design
as well with compact dimensions and a
promise of ample sportiness as with a
sylvestris ancestor the 208 GTI has a
wider toe than the regular 208 by one
centimeter in back and two in front the
rear spoiler and diffusers stressed the
GTI sporting ambitions puzzled Sasha
points out the GTI's 147 kilowatt
gasoline-powered engine is 15 kilowatt
stronger than the VW polos gti's it'll
go from 0 to 100 km/h in 6.8 seconds
topping out at 230 also means that
speeds leg then of course the co2
emissions not so green it's not recess
Slayton's the 208 GTI has plenty of
cargo space for its size at least enough
to accommodate one or two suitcases
did Sasha says the interior is also
sporty and stylish especially likes the
colored plastic trim effete musicals the
same colors show up in the door handles
to a nice detail is the aluminum pedal
pads the dashboard is covered with
imitation leather a touch of luxury in
the poo shows all-round sporty feel so
they leave I've sasha was the [ __ ] oh
208 GTI rivals the VW Polo GTI the Opel
Corsa OPC at wendys three and it's
racing version and there are no Clio RS
in terms of technical data the pooja 208
GTI has little to fear from its
competition even if its fuel consumption
bring it at 5.9 litres per hundred
kilometers is a bit optimistic after all
a GTI is meant to be driven like a
sports car in terms of performance the
pooja 208 GTI has a lot to offer and
starting in twenty two thousand nine
hundred euros in Germany it's the best
priced car of its kind sasha says going
a180 kilometres an hour the wind is so
loud that it really bothers him even so
his general impression is a positive one
all the specs are in order and the price
is right when dr. price is there swing
you
the Porsche 911 the iconic sports car
introduced in 1963 the throaty roar of
its air-cooled engine became the 911s
trademark several years after the car
was introduced Porsche came out with the
more powerful 911s by Zika our test
driver says it could hit 220 kilometers
an hour and go from 0 to 100 in under
seven seconds a real sensation he knows
that a lawyer deemed such performance
criminal in the 1960s many Germans
bought their first cars and started
hitting the highway most of the vehicles
couldn't begin to keep pace with the
racy 911 the car's performance and
handling often overwhelmed ordinary
drivers
at night Kristin Bauer says because the
motor is located behind the rear axle
the car tends to oversteer occasionally
the rear end comes out of a curve first
which is why the driver's handbook
includes the warning not suited for
beginners but he says this just made the
car more attractive trading cars with
unique handling is a Porsche tradition
as are the two auxiliary seats in the
back the 356 Porsches first series
production model was as good at
transporting families as it was at
taking sharp curves the prototype for
its successor the 911 followed the same
basic concept its rear engine made for
good traction whether on slippery
surfaces or on the racetrack even today
the 911 still uses a rear-mounted engine
the original car body from 1963 was
designed by Ferdinand Alexander Porsche
he was just 28 at the time the cars
timeless lines in elegant silhouette
still have the power to thrill they
provided the blueprint for the 911s that
followed the car shallow but spacious
trunk offers more space than most sports
cars with an engine speed of up to 7200
rpm and a five-speed gearbox which
allowed for swift shifts from second to
third the 911 is a race car drivers
dream as is its 160 horsepower boxer
engine with its two liters of cubic
capacity this Porsche 911s is from the
site house Classic Car Museum in wolf
war with its top speed of 220 km/h the
911s was Germany's fastest series
production car a true milestone in
automotive history our test driver says
it's so wrong sporty and with the
tachometer in the middle you know what's
important it feels the car sporty
agility really kicks in from 4,000 rpm
and that's fun
after the first test drives car journal
is praised the 911s for the sum of its
extraordinary parts these included
things like it's excellent performance
and good workmanship
when the le isn't it wonderful
Christophe our ass he says the 911s
being built today are just facelift
versions of this original which made its
debut at the frankfurt motor show in
1963 no other sports car has been so
successful in motorsports and in sales
figures he claims but he says it's
little wonder as it's a sports car
that's suited for everyday use while the
handling takes a bit of getting used to
due to the engines position behind the
rear axle he notes that this produces
good traction on mountain roads like
this it makes for extremely fun driving
but this fun had its price in 1966 and
911s cost twenty four and a half
thousand German marks as much as five VW
beetles still it proved a lucrative
investment as models in good condition
fetch more than fifty thousand euros
today
the way this cars propelled from behind
puts a smile on our testers face he says
that while the six-cylinder engine only
votes 160 horsepower it's just wonderful
to feel that power behind you the first
911s delivers Porsches characteristic
driving pleasure and its purest form and
for that we're even willing to overlook
the cars high fuel consumption of more
than 15 liters of super per 100
kilometers
as it is all done Christophe says this
Porsche has everything he wants in a car
it looks fabulous is suited to everyday
use is comfortable yet sporty and
dynamic he thinks you can do anything
with it bring the kids to school go
shopping and tear up Italian mountain
passes does it get better than this he
asset he also likes at the car isn't a
diva like many of its air quality that
title as one of the few super sports car
is the first 911s like its successors is
as good for everyday driving as it is on
the racetrack so it's only fitting that
the car from silfen housing has become
one of the world's best-loved sports
cars